yank speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
[Applause]
yang
in the middle of this pandemic while our
federal government seems more concerned
with
you know bailing out corporations and
institutions and businesses
you know we need to fight for a people's
bailout and then the george floyd
protests
i think really had me go back to dr king
who was talking about the guaranteed
income
during a similar time in this nation's
history when there was 253
riots across the nation of people who
are protesting and saying enough is
enough
the guaranteed income is really about
dignity we can have
better systems that really um lift the
whole nation as a whole
well michael and i were on a panel you
said to me after the panel you said
andrew you can say [ __ ] i could never
get away with saying
i really took that to heart michael's
one of the things that came
through to me during the campaign was
that like we each have
a message and unfortunately or
fortunately
like the message and the messenger
really get tied up together
uh today in america you know it's like
like we could all be saying the same
thing and it would be
interpreted very very differently based
upon uh who
we are the messenger is really important
and it really takes all of us coming
together
to push this this needle forward
[Music]
hello everyone and thank you for being
here welcome to yang
speaks we have three incredible leaders
on
the show this time uh mayor
michael tubbs who you may know as the
champion
and leader of mayors for guaranteed
income something very near and dear
to my heart and hopefully most of you
listening
uh to this and if you don't like basic
income then you're in the wrong place
clearly my name is andrew yang and i you
know
i've been running on this for quite some
time uh mayor of holyoke massachusetts
alex morris who's also running for
congress in his district
uh we've endorsed him uh so you
definitely need to get behind
alex in his race and then the most
important person because i don't know
her quite as well i was saying to her
before it's like i know mayor tubbs and
uh and mayor morris a little too
too well so there's they're less
interesting
uh the mayor compton asia brown welcome
welcome to each and every one of you
thank you so much it's great to be here
thanks for having me you're all
right yeah you're all incredible awesome
young next-gen leaders who are
championing basic income so i have
two goals for this because i've been in
your shoes i mean alex is an active
candidate right now so every minute of
his time is super valuable
and you're all mayors so like an hour of
your time is super valuable so i have
two goals
three let's say uh number one is to
drive value for each of you because
that's just
the way we roll so we got to try and
make sure that alex gets some support
and each of you
hopefully make your case the second
thing
is to talk about mayors for a guaranteed
income and that organization
uh how it came about what the goals are
and what we can do to help
and the third thing is for each of you
to actually enjoy yourselves which i
know is going to be
tough but i've been in your shoes where
you're like the candidate
or the pro or the mayor and you come on
and you seem really
smart and profound and caring and
idealistic and
you know like i i want us to actually
try and have a good time with this
instead
instead of each of you just like putting
on the game face because i have the game
face too
i can put that [ __ ] on
i want you all to feel like this is like
a time where you can actually
uh commune a bit um and let your hair
down
so michael let's start with you and
mayors for a guaranteed income
how the heck did this come about i know
a little bit of the back story
um but would love to hear from you
exactly
how you got started yeah so well first
thanks for having us andrew
thank you for your working leadership
thank you mayor brown and mayor morse
not just for leading on this issue but
on nearly
every issue on anything mayor brown was
just in paper today talking about let's
investigate
and make sure that those who are s who
spoiler protected and served
aren't part of any crazy like law
enforcement gangs i think as a
woman as a black woman to be out in
front and say no no let's do a
federal state investigation just points
to kind of the leadership that
um you two and all the other mayors as
part of the network provide
a lot of it came andrew partly from
watching just how
when you made the decision to run for
president primarily on this idea of a
guaranteed universal basic income how
much momentum from the
the idea attracted and seeing how you're
giving me too much credit michael
you're giving me too much credit you
were on this stuff before i arrived on
the scene
but but it was it it it made it very
clear how it was a national it was a
the nation was more ready for it than
many people anticipated
um so then during the covet 19 and sort
of seeing
how for the folks in the stockton pilot
which we launched in february 2019
so many of them were persisting because
of this 500
that they were lucky to get and how it
allowed one lady who was covet positive
to take two weeks off for work
he allowed another person who didn't get
access to unemployment benefits
a stable sort of income for three months
while they waited to get unemployment
rolls and had me thinking like before
i was all in but after seeing kind of
covet 19 and some people on the work i
said no this has to be something that
has to be national and something that
a lot of the other mayors would get get
on board with and then the george floyd
protest
which we know it's not just about police
brutality but about the violence of
poverty the violence of lack of
opportunity
i think really had me go back to dr king
who was talking about a guaranteed
income
during a similar time this nation's
history when there was 253
riots across the nation of people who
were protesting and saying enough is
enough and i think it was colvin 19 and
george floyd
that made me realize that a lot of
mayors were actually already thinking
about or working on doing this like a
week before
we talked to mara brown she was already
doing something we give directly
with folks with snap benefits and so
many others and it felt it was time for
all of us
to bring our collective energy and
collective voice to an issue that i
think speaks to
um the pain of so many of our
constituents this idea that we're
working hard that we're creating value
but we don't see that translating into
the ability to pay bills
the ability to pay for food and the
basic ability to stay home when you're
sick so you don't spread
covet 19. well
michael and i were on a panel what was
it two years ago now i guess the
your trial was just getting started
three years ago three of 2017
no yeah it was october 2017.
i guess i believe you man time has
flowed uh so we're in a panel about
basic income
uh annie lowry moderated it was
wonderful it was in los
angeles it was a very nice event and
then you said to me after the panel you
said andrew you can say [ __ ] i could
never get away with saying
anyways because i was going whole hog
after the fact it's like look we have to
stop
uh treating human value and economic
values the same things like if we
persist in that we're doomed because
we're going to automate away so much of
the
the current uh labor force
uh and i really took that to heart
michael it's one of the things that
um that came through to me during the
campaign was that
like we each have a message and
unfortunately
or fortunately like the message and the
messenger really get tied up together
uh today in america you know it's like
like we could all be saying the same
thing and it would be
interpreted very very differently based
upon uh who
we are uh so aja i know that
it sounds like michael's been whispering
basic income in your ear for quite some
time and and also
you were working on something
independently before
um eight mayors for agi became
officially a thing would love to hear
about your experience and i know
you grew up in tough circumstances a
single mom
like in the area and so you've
experienced what
the impact of poverty can be in terms of
not just
financial goals but in terms of your
health
your stress your ability to learn
absolutely well first andrea thanks for
having me
i've said it privately but i'll say it
publicly i just thank you for your
leadership um and bringing these
ideas really to the forefront and the
mainstream
as everyone said the messenger is really
important and it really takes all of us
coming together
to push this this needle forward and for
michael tubbs he is a great friend of
mine
i call him my brother my little brother
and he has just been a tremendous leader
as i've always known him to be
in the space of bringing justice
inequality to all people
the guaranteed income is really about
dignity that regardless of your
circumstance you deserve to live a life
that is free of
terror from the basic necessities of
having to
continually move i i shared earlier
briefly that i grew up with a single
mother
and have a twin brother so she needed
everything double time for
for us and that meant that i took the
back seat um
a lot of times with making requests to
be a part of community or
extracurricular activities and i was
always cognizant that my mother just
could not afford
those things and those are those that's
the the stress levels and the
considerations that little children
are impacted by by not having a stable
and
a basic income floor and so i know
firsthand as i said that having a few
hundred dollars extra a month could mean
everything to communities to people that
live in poverty
my mother for one if she i know for a
fact if she had an additional 200
a month that when car repairs came up um
it wouldn't mean that my family had to
move because my mom had to decide
of fixing her car in order to go to work
so that we can continue
moving forward and having to find a new
apartment and so this was a cycle
that i grew up in and that's not
something that any family should uh
deal with in the most wealthiest nation
of america uh we've gotten away from
um the the really core values of america
where the american dream was attainable
to all people and we know that that's
not the case especially in a nation
where
uh the wealth rests with the the top one
percent of the population
um and that that's just cannot be and
especially when it's real
literally physically impossible for most
people to spend that wealth and even if
they spend uh money every single day
continuously they still can spend all
the wealth that they've acquired and so
it just makes sense to be able to
redirect that money to
the bottom 99 so that people can live
with dignity and that we can jump start
our economy and that we can
have better systems that really um lift
the whole nation as a whole
um and so i'm really committed to this
work when as i said
michael tubbs is a champion um i when he
calls i'm
always there for him and when he was
able to navigate and
resurrect this basic income program many
people
called him a socialist and they it was
really derogatory he took a lot of heat
uh on
in every level from the political realms
and in the trenches and i'm sure in his
community
but he is a tremendous leader thought
leader
and i look forward to seeing what he
does not obviously not only in stockton
but on the national stage because he's
making a difference literally
throughout communities across the nation
yeah mayor tubbs star just keeps rising
i mean he was featured in the cpo
documentary
uh that just came out uh you know he has
a
now he's a dad um so so that that that's
giving him a couple more sleepless
nights i'm sure
[Laughter]
uh so uh alex so alex and i literally
were just on a zoom together last night
um because we've endorsed alex's
campaign
um uh alex it's like my one of my like
favorite
political figures in the country in part
because he went to
brown where i went and then he was
turned right around and went back to his
hometown and i joked last night that
that is not the usual brown university
thing to do like the brown university
thing to do is to move to brooklyn
move to your hometown uh and then become
mayor at age 22.
he's been mayor now for um i guess like
four terms or whatever because they're
like two-year terms
it's nuts right um they just changed it
to four-year terms and now he's running
for congress
against this uh congressman um neil
um who i think nancy pelosi just cut an
ad for him
um which did not um do anything to sway
me
from endorsing alex in this race uh
because
you know i think alex is the future of
western mass so
alex would love to hear uh about your
journey
and how you also came to join this
coalition of mayors for guaranteed
income
great well thank you again for having me
andrew and great to be with you for
back-to-back events and of course want
to thank mayor tubbs and mayor brown for
uh for their leadership and partnership
as colleagues and i've known mayor tops
for for quite a bit and just want to
echo what
uh mayor brown said about mayor tubbs
for really leading the way on the
on the local level for a guaranteed
income and
piloting this and talking about this and
amplifying this cause
well before it became part of the
political mainstream uh if i can say
it's there
and so thank you for yeah thank you for
your leadership uh mayor and proud to
join this coalition
alongside you and um again thank you
andrew for for your leadership during
your campaign
and as you know in the midst of this
pandemic this has become more relevant
and important than than ever before
and you know i talked a little bit about
holyoke's a city of 40 000 people right
outside springfield and i say it's a
a small city with big city challenges we
were once the paper city of the entire
country the first planned industrial
city in
in the united states and because the
forces of capitalism and globalization
we
fell on hard times those factories
shuttered jobs moved down
south and overseas at the very time new
people came to our community
and today we're we're largely we're 50
latino
mostly of puerto rican descent and the
jobs that were once available to irish
immigrants and polish immigrants
were not available to puerto rican
migrants in our in our community and so
for years policymakers and mayors have
struggled with well how do we
create jobs and build wealth for people
in our community and
when i think about the the fact that we
focus on entrepreneurship and built
in wealth building opportunities for for
people in our community not
not sort of seeking large corporations
coming in so our residents can make
minimum wage jobs but how do we give
people the tools they need
to start their own business and build
wealth for themselves and for their
families
it's why i'm a strong supporter of a
single-payer health care system
and why i'm a strong supporter of a
guaranteed income
in the middle of this pandemic while our
federal government seems more concerned
with
you know bailing out corporations and
institutions and businesses
you know we need to fight for a people's
bailout people here in holyoke we
already have a high population of folks
that are food insecure
housing insecure that are concerned with
how to put food on the table and pay
their rent
pay their mortgage and now with the
incredible reduction in the economy the
fact that our economy shrunk by what
over 33
in the last quarter our gdp by 10 our
economy is not going to return to the
way it was before
and so we were already forced to
redefine what what
productivity was who capitalism was
serving
and now it's even more pronounced in in
communities like holyoke
and communities across the country and
so this is really about you know as
as mayor brown said basic humanity and
dignity for our people
and what choices people can make like
can you start that business
can you be a mother or a father and and
and and take care of your kids at the
same time or do you have to choose
between working
to provide for your family or being
there for your child
and and no person in this country in the
wealthiest country on earth
should have to make that decision and
clearly we're ill-prepared
in terms of policy and legislation to
meet families where they're at and so
i'm incredibly excited to join with
mayor brown and mayor tubbs
and other mayors around the country to
advance this conversation in our
communities
[Music]
all right this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by raycon
earbuds so i've had expensive earbuds
before
and i always lose them and then i get
mad about how expensive they are
and raycon earbuds are half the price in
just 6. so their new ones
the everyday e25 earbuds
are pretty fantastic they play for six
hours they bloom
they bluetooth connect your phone easily
you've got heavy bass on there like
celebrities love these things like snoop
dogg and
j.r smith and mike tyson um are rocking
these raycon
earbuds so they're pretty freaking cool
and we've got a good deal for you
because you listen to yang speaks so if
you go to
buy raycon r-a-y-c-o-n so b-u-y buy
raycon.com
yang you get 15 off your order try these
things
they're less expensive than some of the
premium earbuds you're hearing out there
and they work just as well so you're not
as stressed about losing them and the
quality is fantastic buy raycon dot com
slash yang 50
off raycon wireless earbuds by
raycon.com
[Applause]
uh alex i'm so excited for your race
like there's such a paradigm shift going
on where
uh you have your corporate funded
opponent who's been sitting there for
years and decades
uh and then uh you have you and you guys
are raised
almost as much as they have despite the
fact that in your case it's all small
donors
uh grassroots donors i donated myself
uh to your campaign we all need to
support you and make sure you win
um i would be so pumped for that the the
the difference between you winning and
and congressman neil winning is so
massive like it would break my heart if
we don't we miss this opportunity
yeah i will say this like i think i
think you are going to win
um and having a champion for basic
ingram in the congress at that level
will be awesome um
i think we're going to make it happen uh
really thanks to you the fact that
you're like and i
know and i and i your your support means
the world to me and to our team and
you're right we've raised over a million
dollars at this point from nearly 20 000
rashford's individual contributions
according to my math that's fifty
dollars each
uh yeah ninety five percent 100 and i'm
running against a member of congress
that
takes the most amount of corporate money
of any member of the house democrat
and republican he just took the top spot
away from republican kevin mccarthy
and that's from wall street and big
pharma and pharmaceutical companies
and he's even again publicly denounced
and come out against the paycheck
guarantee act
he's come out against monthly recurring
emergency payments throughout the
duration
of this pandemic and even has a gall to
site that cite the deficit you know
something oftentimes reserved for folks
on the right and so he just fails to
meet the urgency
of this moment and you know it's time we
actually send unbought democrats
to washington it's not enough to be a
democrat you have to be a democrat that
actually wants to represent and fight
for people
anyone who's worried about the deficit
right now is worried about the wrong
thing that's for sure we need to worry
about human beings and families in our
communities
um so michael how does this work like
let's say
so how many mayors are in mayors for a
guaranteed income right now and then
what is the commitment like when asia
and you were connecting uh maybe you had
the same conversation and ajo was like
okay what does it take to join this
awesome coalition is there like uh like
a set of principles or a pledge or a
commitment like what does it look like
yeah so um it's about 20 mayors now and
very very very low threshold really
it's number one um commit to piloting or
doing something in your city
because we know that we just need more
kind of stories we could point to
because data doesn't move policy like it
should but stories that look like the
american people do
um so commit to piloting a guaranteed
income of some sort in your city
i'm over the next year um the second
commitment was there's a time frame on
that
like uh over the next year well the way
we're fundraising that's what it's
looking like
and that's kind of the intention so i
think most cities will have something up
before the end of
this year like a plan and next year the
vast majority should be ready to pilot
um number two would be to advocate
particularly during this time for a
guaranteed covet income
um so we've sent letters we've had
briefings with leadership we've had
briefings with the cbc
we've sent even more letters we've been
tweeting we've been doing
interviews and just showing that
throughout this nation that all
all mayors who are on the front lines
and see small businesses closing
see folks who are literally working all
day as essential workers and then have
to go to the food bank at night to get
food because they still have enough
money
and we're seeing just the how the
that to your point and you the focus the
conversation oftentimes is on the wrong
thing we're at a great depression type
of moment and the fact that unemployment
insurance is the only ha
trick we have in the bag where
unemployment insurance is a response to
a 1935 pandemic
we're now in 2020 we have to add until i
understand how the economy works
so number two advocating um and those
are really the two big commitments and
and not being
afraid to speak about i love the way you
said it mayor brown
we're talking about not just a
guaranteed income we're talking about
universal human dignity
we're talking about what you've been
doing i should have run on that
uhd yes
what world do we want people to live in
and and what agency as mayor moore
says we want people to have we want
people to have the agency to decide
where to work how they work what
businesses started we're seeing right
now
that we live in a society unfortunately
that does not provide dignity to all
people that has to change
uh aja i would love to hear from you so
you joined
uh and then now you have some kind of um
pilot in mind and the thing that that uh
i reflect on is that if you're a mayor
you're getting pulled in a lot of
different directions you've got a lot of
different budgetary priorities
and so when you commit to having one of
these pilots you're like okay like where
do i get the money for this thing
um do i get it out of the existing
budget do i get it from philanthropic
sources so what does that consideration
look like
for you as a mayor for me
i have definitely come into a city that
had financial challenges not unlike
stockton
and so i recognized that in order to get
this pilot off the ground it's going to
require
private donors and commitments and so
for me that means fundraising that means
creating and working collaboratively
with potential donors on a pilot that
would
be effective for my community
specifically i'm
focusing on measuring and competing the
impacts of
ptsd and how this uh
this basic income will change um how
people feel um how they their outlook on
life
their ability to be present with their
children and educate
their kids and spend quality time their
ability to actually
think beyond the immediate and plan for
a life
in the next several years and thinking
long term like starting a business or
having an impact and then i really like
to
gauge how people are able to expand
their time when they're not so focused
on
the basic necessities what shall they do
could they find hobbies i mean
and that's something that people that
have grown up poor
realize that a lot of people don't have
hobbies they're literally
in survival mode i mean so finding out
do you like the garden do you like to
work out i mean do you like to read i'll
be just
finding basic things that the normal
person or the average person it sounds
far too ambitious aja
someone do something that is not
directly translating into
right uh immediate compensation like i
i don't know what you're suggesting here
suggesting
like uh like actually like leisure time
um like that this is totally
unacceptable
um so uh well i love that
um and one thing that michael you just
suggested is that people respond to
other people and other stories
i had the same feeling on the trail
where i was arguing to give everyone
money
and then i started giving a thousand
bucks a month to families in iowa and
new hampshire
and the funny thing is that there were
like these campaign finance rules in
place
where um it was unclear what the
restrictions were and like whether i can
do that and so one thing we
figured out was 100 uh like above board
that no one could dispute
is that i could just as a private
citizen give someone else a thousand
bucks a month
um and uh so that's what i did and the
embarrassing thing was actually was
writing personal checks
um and uh like uh there was like one
month where like i'd forgotten to send
the checks because i was kind of busy
running
then i get like a text message from
someone being like hey
uh you know that that like that was like
oh my gosh i'm so sorry and then i i
turned around but we did that in part so
that people could see it
uh people could um see their neighbor
getting the money
and just now we had millions of
americans who got twelve hundred dollars
uh in april and it was not enough um but
i
i think that they really enjoyed the
experience
that it also put to bed a lot of
ridiculous myths around like oh it's
gonna make you lazy like oh you're gonna
turn around and like do something
terrible with it
uh so alex on your side when you make
this commitment to
mayors for agi like what is your thought
on on funding sources since it sounds
like aja's
turning around and fundraising from
private donors do you think that's what
most mayors
are going to do and you think that
that's your approach too
yeah i think i think first and foremost
it's it's being able to prove that this
uh you know the pilot itself will be
successful in the impact it has on our
local economies and on our families
uh but i've also said you know number
one as a mayor and as a candidate for
congress
like universal basic income and policies
that work for working people and
families
shouldn't be reserved for the private
sector and so you know thankful to
you know corporations and donors and
philanthropists that
have invested in this movement because
they're helping us get closer to proving
to
to folks at the federal level that this
is a worthwhile investment in actual
people
uh but i wanna you know in my current
capacity as mayor
you know amplify and elevate the need
for government to make this investment
uh and as a future member of congress
you know elevate this at the
at the federal level that yeah even
after a one-time payment of 1200
which wasn't near enough we saw poverty
rates go down for the first time
in decades and so you know people are
struggling with well how do we tackle
poverty how do we level the playing
field it's
well let's actually give folks money and
so that they can pay pay their bills and
actually stimulates the economy
and when people got twelve hundred
dollars they were using it to invest
back in the
back in the economy to to make sure they
have basic things for themselves and
their families i mean nearly 50
percent of the american people have lost
some sort of income or job in the middle
of this pandemic and so
again this has only advanced and
accelerated the need for
a guaranteed income and and again i
think this is something that the
government
should be investing at the end of the
day but until we get there and have the
political you know capital
and and and movement behind us uh i
think it's important that we take the
time to reach out to folks that will
help us
prove and make the difference uh locally
for now i i've been in
those shoes and it's tough especially
with and again in your cases because
you're mayors and you have
like you're getting stretched in all
these different directions they're all
of these worthy projects for you
um i totally agree with you alex and all
of you that this needs to be
something at the government level but
in the meantime we're often relying upon
private philanthropy
so humanity forward is running a very
small
basic income trial that may or may not
be the same scale that ends up
materializing in the 20 cities
that are part of uh mayors for agi maybe
700 000
uh or so we're giving it to uh perhaps
uh 25 to 30 different families over a
period of time
and we're hoping to document the results
and have
filmmakers and storytellers like follow
the families
and we raised that money privately uh
which is something that you know i'm
very grateful
for um so i'm trying to imagine ways
that we could make it so that this
is like a slam dunk for dozens hundreds
of mayors to join in on
uh and and to me if i'm a mayor looking
at this i'm like okay well the first
thing is like do i believe in
some sort of uh basic income as a policy
and to me
like if you're a mayor looking around at
what's going on your community like like
at this point it's uh completely obvious
that we need to do something like this
like you you can't
sincerely be looking to try and solve
your
constituents problems and say like you
know what would not be helpful to all
these folks right now
like you know 500 bucks a month a
thousand bucks a month whatever it is
uh and 74 of americans agree on cash
relief during covid
so the vast majority of your
constituents are going to be on board
with that
uh so i feel like the main um
impediment for mayors joining is going
to be something around funding
um michael is that like a correct read
um because if i was a mayor looking at
it like that would be
like the concern i'd have is like okay
where am i going to get the money
for this pilot if i run it i think
that's part of it but it's been really
interesting in conversations we've had
with many mayors who haven't joined yet
it feels still a little bit scary and
risky
i think oftentimes because even if
you're a mayor
you hear your constituents stories but
by the time you're a mayor you have a
stable income so i think you're really
insulated to like the actual
economic impacts are happening
particularly because everything's on
zoom
you're not having town hall meetings
you're not out and about as you used to
so there's
even some mayors i call friends they
seem to have a different
understanding of what's actually
happening on the ground
with their constituents and also i think
because the merit position you're
the executive you have to think about
all the ramifications you think of it
when you you
think about everything i think it causes
a lot of people to be a little trigger
shy
and a little bit uh scared to to
challenge and to push
i'm not really understanding what this
moment is unprecedented one
and unemployment insurance in and of
itself is not going to get there
because again 40 of people in california
who qualify for unemployment insurance
still have not received a check and
their bills are still coming through so
i think part of it is the budgetary
issue but i think part of it is also
just
evolving mindsets i think so many people
want to believe
we live in the country like we've been
taught that if you work hard
that'll be enough to pay the bills that
if you do if you make right decisions if
you're contributing
that your rent will be paid then you can
eat that that
poverty is a function of terrible
personal choices or being economically
insecure it's because you don't know how
to spend money
when as we know that's just not the case
that's not how
the economy has ever worked but
particularly doesn't work that way um
today as kovit's making it clear so
we're doing a lot of work and calling in
our other mayors and actually
the u.s conference of mayors blueprint
for america
will include basic income as something
that um
congress should enact we also passed a
resolution from the u.s conference of
mayor so we're seeing
more and more momentum and i think as we
get more and more through this covert
process you'll see more males come on
board
[Music]
here at yang speaks we think your data
should be yours
and you know who doesn't really think
that anymore the internet the internet
thinks that your data should belong to
various
tech companies and data brokers are
going to sell and resell it and one way
to put a stop to all that
is to use expressvpn vpn stands for
virtual private network
an expressvpn is one of the best worlds
number one rated by cnet wired the verge
countless others uh we use it just push
a button and then it's like you're
logging on to your own private internet
you can even stick it in europe where
you can
access european programming that they
don't allow
here i don't know what those shows are
um
i actually i think i saw one there's
like titans that was not
all that's like not allowed for us but
it's allowed for
the folks abroad anyway if you are
like me and you think that your data
should be yours
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
yang today use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com yang and you can get an extra
three months for free at expressvpn.com
and aj i would love your perspective on
uh
what the what you think we could do to
make it so that other mayors
feel like the water's warm or the water
is safe
and um one thing i'm going to suggest to
folks who are watching this or listening
to this is to
actually write or call your mayor and
say hey you know it's a really good idea
of like basic income you should really
do that
join this mayor's for agi and um
it's gonna be very positive for you your
people
uh the energy around your uh your
leadership
um what would you suggest aja if
someone's listening to this
and trying to think okay how can i get
my mayor on board
i think reaching out is just critical i
can tell you that when
we announced the um mayors for
guaranteed basic income
and residents from other communities
reached out to our office asking if i
can contact
their mayor for them because they want
them to join uh gpi
and so it's something that once people
understand that it's out there that
there's a movement for that
then they definitely want to be a part
of it and i think
as michael tubbs is doing i'm leading
the way with positive peer pressure
looking at different angles and then
just presenting data but as we all have
said
on today is that stories are everything
and i think that if there's an
opportunity to have a budget to just
communicate to
the mayors at large or communities at
large about the the impacts of basic
income
and really i'd love to see just some
stories from the stockton pilot about um
how that pilot impacted their life and i
think that when you hear that people are
able to have
less stress more dignity able to just
branch out and expand as a human being i
don't think that any mayor that has a
concern or care or love for their
community could negate that so
i think sharon's stories are critical
we're putting pressure a positive
pressure on mayors
through the u.s conference of mayors and
other formats but
people are usually touched by things
that come to their doorstep so i know
that as we are able to continue to scale
up and communicate
more that that will be a great platform
and even
with docustories and various means there
are different platforms um
60-second docs that there's different as
everyone is more connected um
through cobit we can definitely use
social media and do a robust
campaign targeted to mayors and targeted
to these communities that we'd like to
see come on board as well so
i think we just have to use every means
necessary
to put that pressure um and and really
raise the bar because
what we're talking about is not um a
political
um ploy this this is about you know it
is it's not a gimmick
it's not about uh you know being liberal
or or conservative we're talking about
humanity and so we have to take those
confines off and think about
how do people in america deserve to live
and if people are not
living with that basic threshold then we
have work to do and that we it's it's
beholden of us to think about ways to be
able to ensure that that quality of life
i mean and we're and we've fallen short
and so we we have to commit to doing
that work
uh alex you became mayor at 22 uh which
is
obviously like i'm sure you were the
youngest mayor of your city i'd like you
are all the youngest mayors of your
cities in history i think i think that's
like a common thread here
um and so you had to go against the
grain a lot that's true for all of you
uh like how do mayors commune with each
other
and the fact that you have these 20
mayors now
and rising like yeah like like what
what does that network look like and
what does
quote unquote like peer pressure on
mayors look like and i'll speak from my
perspective
my goal is to make it so that's just a
political no-brainer to be for this
uh that you win you don't lose and
everyone just likes you more
you know like that that's my goal uh
that
like you get more support donations
visibility
love humanity like all of it but um like
what what has your experience been in
terms of the way that
mayors uh learn about things that might
help their community and what can we do
to help yeah no that's that's a good
question
it's so interesting because you know
mayors obviously we oversee
the boundaries of our of our borders of
our municipality and so so often
we see these issues as only caring about
things that are happening inside of our
communities and so when it comes to
you know luring jobs or tax revenue you
know we think
oh it's traditionally mayors would think
it's a good thing if a company moves
from one neighboring community into
their community
um as if it's um as if it's on take away
and add here
when we're really regional economies and
a national economy and we should be
collaborating and
you know not every corporation or
company would would be a good fit in
holyoke like what are our competitive
advantages
and assets that make it that that make
like
it it natural for certain industries and
companies to come to the city of holyoke
and i think i mentioned last night
you know i opposed a casino coming to
town when i first ran for mayor
we blocked a walmart coming to town
because it had a net negative impact on
our local economy
and exploited residents here hurt small
businesses
and you know partner with local uh labor
unions and activists
uh to pretty much prevent them from
coming to the city but
it's more than it's sort of looking at
issues globally and
and regionally we have a network of
mayors in western massachusetts
we have a statewide network of mayors in
in the entire state here
and then as mayor brown alluded to the
united states conference of mayors where
there's different task forces and and
coalitions based on the particular issue
whether it's climate or
telecommunications or
in this case a guaranteed income and i
don't think this should be one of those
things as was already stated that
we should have to expand much political
capital on convincing people why this is
important
particularly if you're a mayor of a
community where so many people are left
behind and forgotten about
and i oftentimes say i've been mayor for
nine years we've made a lot of progress
but the longer i've been mayor the more
i get frustrated with our federal
government the fact that over 60 percent
of our federal budget goes to the
pentagon and goes to war and defense and
pennies go to education
and affordable health care and in
building hospitals and community health
centers
and we haven't had a new school built in
our community in over 32 years
and so mayors like the three of us are
forced to do the best we can
with the resources we have and so if
you're a mayor of a community
where uh where you have any folks that
are at risk of losing their house or are
homeless themselves or struggles but
food on the table
um have fallen through the cracks of a
broken education system
oftentimes we put the burden on people
and families when we
refuse to look inward and think well how
are our institutions and public schools
excluding people and so any reasonable
mayor republican independent democrat
whatever your political affiliation is
if you care deeply about the people you
represent
you will naturally come to the
conclusion that a guaranteed income is
the right policy
uh to move forward i agree with you and
so
i i thought there would be like this
well and it's happening i mean it's gone
from what 10 to 20 and uh
in like just a matter of days michael is
that right
something like that to get the exact
numbers
yeah i i mean when i saw the
announcement i
i think i tweeted like why the [ __ ]
would you not join this
i thought it's like if you're a mayor
it's like what is my dad's side here
and i agree with you alex that
that uh cities have generally
uh balanced budgets that they have to
meet i mean you might be able to borrow
money or issue bonds a little bit like
here and there but like you can't just
go out and like you know
like print gobs of money uh states have
these balanced budget
amendments very often i think 40 out of
50 you need to have a balanced budget
and then you have the feds who are just
like what is going on over there it's
like hundreds of billions
and like and the money's not going to
improve our way of life
uh and that if i were a mayor i
completely agree i would have come to
this conclusion but like what is going
on like why are we
being forced to like try and uh like
stretch pennies until they break
uh and not get a new school for decades
and
have our infrastructure crumble and have
all these things just go to
pot like underneath us um and
and this is like something that's true i
think of american society generally
particularly
since we've all been brainwashed by
capitalism and the meritocracy and the
and
the other nonsense is that like pretty
much everyone has to have like a can-do
attitude like if you're a mayor
and your factory closed and things are
going bad and like your you know schools
are depleted and people are addicted to
drugs
like and then someone sticks a mic in
front of your face you have to be like
you know we can do it
we're going to come back stronger
everything's going to be all right and
the rest of it
uh and then you look around being like
you know what would actually you know
what really help matters
is if we put money into people's hands
we built a new school we got some
genuine resources for the folks who are
struggling with addiction
you know like actually tried to create
an economy the 21st century as opposed
to the 20th
so or the 19th i mean hell like you know
like who the heck knows what's
and i've been all around the country and
so i've seen these towns
and you feel for the leadership there
because you feel like so many of the
mayors are sticking band-aids on top of
freaking like deep infections and deep
wounds you know and they're like
slapping the band-aid on and being like
hey
i got the band-aid on you know like
you're being forced into these
ridiculous
uh you know contortions and exertions
that that aren't necessary so that's my
mini rant
i suppose
well this is going to be a lot of fun
because i get to talk to you about a
podcast i've been on three times zach's
heading on
one of my favorite podcasts there is
nerds for humanity tom
over at nerds for humanity is head on
tim ryan
anthony scaramucci john mcafee
but more importantly he's like a lot
like me
frankly in that he just loves data where
he's got these tables and charts
and data breaking down major policy
issues current events it really is like
a math
make america think harder type podcast
so check it out and subscribe to nerds
for humanity their podcast and youtube
channel
and you too will be saying hello
nerds which is what they say at the
beginning of every news for humanity
podcast
hey tom you're the best man
[Applause]
i would would love to hear from each of
you really what we can do to help
like if there is a specific thing that
you're working on that we can do to help
move mares for a guaranteed income
forward because i think what you're
doing is so important
and what i said before about the message
in the messenger it's like you all
are fantastic messengers and leaders
and the people in your community when
they see uh basic income in action as
they have already in stockton
like there's just no denying it everyone
looks up and says okay that that's
phenomenal and we should do that in more
places so what can we
do to help each of you and there are
going to be
you know thousands and thousands of
people that hear this like what can we
do to help
so i'm going to to uh start with you aja
what can we do to help
you and the folks in compton or the
mayors for agi
you know i'm going to actually ask
michael to start first at the top down
and i can talk
more specifically about compton um he's
the whole team is raising for
the pilot um and to be able to get the
infrastructure necessary so
mike if you want to talk more about the
needs for that um so that we can scale
up with more so
i love it mike we're gonna get inside of
your head and like like the
the uh the master plan for the mayor's
api
like i think the biggest thing
i would say andrew and asia the points
you guys raised
around just a storytelling component
would be super super helpful
and this point you raised andrew about
making the mayors who joined
feel really good about joining would
also be super helpful so like amplifying
with the new merrick joins
i'm telling folks who are part of
humanity forward to reach out to their
mayors i know color of change has been
doing a campaign with a couple of
marriage but they have members
i'm telling them to join but i think
just making the permission structure one
that
feels good it feels like the cool thing
to do and continuing that drumbeat will
be helpful but also just amplifying
um the stories of not just the folks in
stockton but also
um just even the way these mayors talk
about the dignity of their constituents
or
kind of the future of their cities just
the more
i think people hear from a lot of
diversity of voices
around this issue it would be a big help
and then on the further side
regarding conversations about just
working with every mayor
to identify sort of what their needs are
so that we haven't scaled up as quickly
because with the first 20 cities we're
going really deep
and doing hours and hours of ta and
pilot design
just to make sure when we step out we
step out um in a way that
that makes sense so i think um continued
help on the fundraising push for the
marriage we have
three million from jack and from that
every mayor is getting a hundred and
fifty thousand i think or a hundred
thousand two whoa
look at that look at that you joined
this thing and you get a hundred grand
that's incredible
start having having a staff member
someone to sign and then having further
conversations with folks
around whether it's a mix of karazak
relief dollars which you could do
one-time
income stuff with and private funds how
to get there so super long answer but
the short of it is amplification a good
permission structure
and then if there's folks interested in
kind of mayors who are on the ground who
are really the fun just send them
um our way because all the mayors are
ready and literally spending hours and
hours every week on the phone with my
staff and their staff figured out what's
the best way to design
pilots for those cities so just to dig
into that for a second
so you started with several million
dollars and then you put
let's call it 100 to 150 k to work to
help each city get set up
is that right yeah so we thought for for
to your point about making a celebration
that because these marriages were doing
so much work it
a lot of it's time and we're still in
the midst of pandemics there's still
mass civil unrest
yeah we need to so we gave them money so
here's money once you give us a work
plan and with that you can hire a staff
person
you can whatever you need to do create a
task force but here's some funding some
seed fighting to get you started you can
also go back to your community with like
no i'm doing something like this is
moving forward
so if you were a private philanthropist
and you wanted to help because i you
know i
figured there must be a few listings to
this
uh so they can give straight to mayors
for agi and then that money can go out
to help
other folks um start developing work
plans is that correct or would it be to
give
specifically to a given cities trial or
both
well it's really up to people so as as a
network we've been fundraising for the
collective but we have also to your
point come across
funders who are interested in funding
something in the la area with the
consortium of la city so we connect them
with the la city team we have folks who
are interested in midwest cities are
interested in cities on the east coast
et cetera so it's
it's donor preference right we just know
we have a all
and literally we have the best mayor
that i get to brag on all the mirrors we
have you do have the best mayors it's
true i don't know if they can tell
from the three of you like i see who
joined and i'm like this is like the
all-star
roster of like my favorite mayors
so so everyone's primed and ready
working now
and i think as soon as there's a
commitment for
more dollars for pilots people be ready
to run but even right now
you heard mayor brown had her research
questions and what she wants to measure
etc mayor morse the same way because
we're serious about this because we
understand that
while we wait for the federal government
to act we can apply more pressure when
we're saying look we're already doing it
without the power
of spinning that you have because we are
really about the people
as you all should be as representatives
of the people in dc
well this is getting me super excited
because if we get the money in place and
these trials start running around the
country then this is
uh unbeatable this is uh inevitable um
so exciting we got to get you more of
the
resources and money and attention
to keep this wave growing i will 100 do
my part
um very exciting like that i mean it's
funny it's like
literally like like i'm getting more
excited i'm like
the guy who sleeps and breathes this
stuff um uh
ajo would love to hear from you what can
we do to help like uh
are there uh funders and oh just one
small thing michael before i
forget there's an nba player who uh
called me um
and asked me about how he could help and
i think i'm gonna send him your way
um like for whatever reason some nba
players seem to be loving universal
basic income
um but he's he's based in california so
i'll do that after this
i think i saw you shoot jump shots on
the campaign trail and was like this guy
got it
yeah that was not it are being
you know it's like you know and you all
will know this i will say that the
standards are so low for a presidential
candidate
like if if you're if you events any kind
of humor humanity everyone's like oh
look at look at that
like this not a total raging lunatic or
[ __ ] like
let's uh let's
let's sign up for this three times um
and andrew i would just recommend that
um
if there's someone that really wants to
roll their sleeves up to consider doing
some crowd fundraising for the
initiative
because we're governmental entities we
do have certain restrictions
from that and so they could definitely
align and be a support and they could
definitely
obviously donate directly to cities i
like compton i'm always on a pub compton
um but
there are other opportunities as well to
just support the system
of mayors as michael tubbs said um and
there's so much alignment and
opportunity and i think that if people
are are really committed they can even
customize somehow their funds are being
utilized to certain pilots that meet
their criteria so it's really
all hands on deck uh situation correct
this is very important let's delve into
this for a second so
let's say i was a small donor i had 50
bucks
and i said i would love to donate this
to a basic income
trial in compton um and so right now
i would be at a loss as to how to do
that um
so are are you suggesting that um that
it would be possible for someone to
either privately set up
a crowdfunding um page or event
and say look this is for the compton
trial
um or like it look is that helpful
it would be helpful if that person
definitely is reputable and will work in
alignment um with the
with the the team um so that we
obviously can track it there's so many
things going on today but um
absolutely they can work in alignment
and utilize their networks and
to help people fund a basic income in
our cities for sure
wow that's so interesting so it sounds
like one thing that might be helpful
because there are 20 mayors but you
could set up something where
it's like a like hey here are the 20
cities you can fund trial in any of
these places
and the amounts might be modest at first
but it could build over time
and that way you could take a load off
of the mayors themselves and their teams
because then you'll have to figure out
okay who's this person are they legit
are they actually gonna get the money uh
in a way it's like maybe we should just
try and set this up
in a way that that everyone trusts
really
and that would help with the donors too
um that's enormous this is
incredible we're getting like more stuff
to do but i love the idea of
crowdfunding those trials because we
um you know we've given seven million
away uh through humanity forward
a lot of that funded by individual
donors uh and people wanna see they're
helping people
um and so if we could set this up for
communities i think it could be very
very powerful
um to your point if i could just say
this briefly um
we already know and alex alluded to this
as well that the
federal government they just literally
failed local communities and
when we think about the amount of money
that is actually um apportioned to local
cities is pennies on the dollars even
for
this cares act is really laughable the
amount of money that uh
compton received in order to to navigate
this global pandemic and it's ridiculous
it's it's outrageous and and government
is so bloated uh with so much red tape
and it literally
it's it's same thing unfortunately at
the state level as well going down to
the county so i just believe in the
the methodology of giving directly to
high five
yeah to have something yeah we've got to
get the money out of the pipes and into
people's hands
right now it's getting stuck up here
it's ridiculous and you know
yeah yeah i would just add to that there
still has been no relief to cities and
towns and
states right now so when we think about
public works and librarians and teachers
and firefighters i mean if
if the federal government doesn't act to
intervene on local budgets
given the impact of this pandemic i mean
the economies i mean the local
government is not going to look like
what local government looked like six
months ago
and so you know mayors like us are also
like what is the future of municipal
government
in a in a covert era and in a postcovid
area era
and we're having incredibly difficult
conversations as to what what what does
the delivery of public services look
like
in the future that pains me so much that
you're having to deal with this
because obviously it's not on any
individual community that we're in the
midst of this pandemic and the last
thing we need is
massive layoffs on top of the job losses
that already exist when you have
an increased need for city and state
workers and not a lower need in many
many
spaces i that makes me very angry uh you
know like the the state aid is a
no-brainer
uh it would just prevent job loss and
help retain the jobs that exist
uh and hopefully even solve some of the
problems we have like trying to
prepare you know it's like like how are
you going to reopen a school
if you didn't have the budget to operate
even under normal circumstances and then
it's like well now you have to
um invest all this in like cleaning and
facilities and staff and staggering like
all the stuff
like we're putting communities in
impossible situations
uh so alex uh what can we do to help you
and i'm going to
do the the pitching again the first
thing we can do is help you win your
race
uh because i think that you should be
the next member of congress
um from your district um and your your
opponent has done himself no favors
uh so the first thing if you're looking
to help alex um go to his website alex
morse
for congress and donate uh you know
whatever you have five bucks doesn't
matter so i'll do that bit
and then what else can we do to help
great i
i appreciate that andrew um i know we
had the event last night i had my
campaign signs behind me
and then i got ready for this call i was
like let's take him down um
you're more disciplined uh you're you're
a good public servant
i i try to be after nine years um now
well i appreciate that and i would just
echo
uh what um mayor thompson mayor brown
said i mean amplifying these stories i
do think a lot of the mayors
still are unaware of the data of how
bleak it is for the vast majority of
of the people in our communities and
across the country and i think
oftentimes when
you're privileged yourself or have
wealth or you know come from a
particular neighborhood or family
you're not so much aware of the lived
experience of the vast majority of
people
in this country and i think the onus has
always been on mayors to show up in
every neighborhood
and talk to the most vulnerable among
you and i think that that is incredibly
helpful and i would just encourage
any just any everyday resident that is
listening to this or paying attention to
a guaranteed income
like local government your mayor is
accountable to you and so
you know show up to local council
meetings show up and contact your mayor
and email them make an appointment um
have a phone call
and and ask your mayor about universal
basic income and a guaranteed income
and have they talked about it and send
them research on it and
you know we can get economic data you
know and and outcomes
for every city in town for people that
are interested in doing this and so
in addition to the crowdfunding and
encouraging donations i think there may
also be an opportunity
to encourage just everyday people around
the country to to reach out to their
elected officials
yes um with some sort of uh data or
fact sheet and and just official
requests that they
that they pursue looking into this for
their community yeah or just good
old-fashioned constituent pressure
because there is no reason why
so we you got like the 20 best coolest
most forward-thinking
young dynamic attractive mayors
in the country on this but like the 20
really should be
200 or how many mayors are there in the
united states of america
thousands probably yeah 2 000. i was
about to say two thousand
nothing that might be like i might have
gone too far i might have just created
extra bears
but but there's but there's no reason
why every mayor should not sign up for
this let's make it happen
i'm going to do my part um you've given
me some work to do which i will gladly
embrace uh because you're working harder
than just about anyone
on this stuff i am so excited for each
of you
uh michael thank you for helping lead
the way
aja you're incredible uh and i'm so glad
we got a chance to meet and alex we got
to get you to dc where you can stay
heads together um so thank you all so
much anyone who's interested in this
mayor's for a guaranteed income follow
each of these incredible leaders because
they
are going to take the entire country in
the right direction
michael tubbs aja brown alex morris
thank you all so much
you're the best i hope i hope this was a
more enjoyable hour than
a lot of the stuff that you uh you
generally do
um and uh profoundly grateful to each of
you
a million percent andrew thank you for
your leadership and good luck
uh mayor with your congressional race
and thank you mayor brown as always for
your leadership and looking forward to
um next steps thank you all so much
just champions for the for the good
people of the united states and
alex we definitely need more mayors in
congress so we'll be rooting for you and
providing some support your way thank
you both so much for your for your
friendship and health and leadership
thank you andrew awesome this is like a
superhero team up
all right thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode